so
[Music]
through the religion of art spirit has
advanced from the form of substance to
assume that of subject for it produces
its outer shape thus making explicit in
it the act or the self-consciousness
that merely vanishes in the awful
substance and does not apprehend its own
self in its trust
this incarnation of the divine being
starts from the statue which wears only
the outer shape of the self the
inwardness the self's activity falling
outside of it
but in the cult the two sides have
become one and in the outcome of the
religion of art this unity in its
consummation has even gone right over at
the same time to the extreme of the self
in spirit that is completely certain of
itself in the individuality of
consciousness all essentiality is
submerged
the proposition that expresses this
levity runs the self is absolute being
the essence the substance for which the
self was only an accident has sunk to
the level of a predicate and in this
self-consciousness over against which
there is nothing in the form of essence
spirit has lost its consciousness
with paragraph
748 we are now beginning a new section
within the religion portion of the work
and this is a very important transition
for reasons i'll tell you about in just
a minute i do want to point out that
there's a lot in these early paragraphs
of this this last section the revealed
religion which is not directly about
revealed religion and is following up on
the
remarks the analysis that hegel
brought before our eyes under the rubric
of comedy you notice that in this
paragraph he actually talks about levity
the proposition that expresses this
levity runs and so we're still dealing
with some of the stuff that happened in
the previous subsection
but we're going to be transforming it
and very quickly hegel is also going to
do some
you know looking backwards at earlier
things particularly at the unhappy
consciousness but the two
other gestalton that preceded its
stoicism and skepticism
now why is this transition so important
we've been doing this throughout the
work we finish a subsection or a section
or a portion and then we move into the
next one we're getting very close to the
end the only thing that is left after
this
section
of religion and the entire religion
portion finishes over these 40
paragraphs including the one that we're
talking about right now yet to come
is the
final section the final portion of the
work that is bringing everything to a
close
absolute knowing and we should remind
ourselves one more time that for hegel
consistently throughout his works
religion is something incredibly
important because it is preparatory too
and needs to be
refined into i almost said purified but
refined is a better term
into philosophy right so we are on the
cusp of that right now and hegel thinks
that the revealed religions
mostly in his view judaism and
christianity are going to be
necessary
dynamics leading to this and
in some sense you know there's a great
remark by stanley rosen
in
his his book on hegel where somebody
you know at one point asked is is hegel
an orthodox christian and uh i don't
remember if rosen's came up with this
quip himself or got it from somebody
else he said well hegel is a christian
but in a church of one namely he's the
only guy in that particular church which
is a little bit ironic even where we're
headed but enough foreshadowing let's
talk about this particular
paragraph
so hegel says that through the religion
of art this entire section that we went
through before
a lot of transitions going on there
through the religion of art spirit has
advanced from
one form to another the form of
substance to assume that of subject and
we've seen this at multiple points you
know and it's it's not just a single
transition from substance to subject
there have been more and more adequate
forms of this going on or we could say
transitions of this going on and finally
we reach the form of subjectivity that
we had in say the last four or five
paragraphs of the religion of art
section
dealing with the spiritual religion and
so all of this is a transition that's
been going on and we're going to see
well what's the difference between
substance and sub subject well
in some respects
substance could be that which
we think is most important you could
consider ancient metaphysics you know
their interest what is lucia what is
what is the thing that remains right and
that could be subject in the
old-fashioned sense of that which lies
underneath but we're thinking here more
of subject as in subjectivity as in
agency
and all of those things that go along
with it
a substance could be a subject you know
think of the traditional concept of god
as you know that which has the greatest
being and
which acts but we've seen there's all
sorts of problems with at least certain
formulations of that for hegel and the
depiction that has to happen
of the god and the question of well who
is the depictor who is the spectator
right so we've had this
important transition take place and he
says that it produces its outer shape
what produces
well spirit
and the form of substance
making explicit in it the act
or the self-consciousness
that merely vanishes in the awful the
not awful like oh terrible but you know
the awesome substance and does not
apprehend its own self in its trust
and then hegel brings up something quite
interesting this incarnation
of the divine being this taking on
shape
form
more literally flesh
this incarnation the divine being starts
from the statue we go all the way back
to
natural religion and the you know the
master worker the artisan right creating
a statue is the statute adequate to the
god no it's static it depicts the god in
one particular way but it provides a
locus for something the statute can mean
much more than itself because
of the other things surrounding it and
he brings up
he says the the inwardness the self
activity falls outside of it and it
could be the self's activity in the
sense of the worshipper could be the the
practitioner it could be the person who
creates the statue or the architecture
or whatever else is going on and then he
brings up the cult
you remember back to how this cult a
community of warship uh which is not
just at one point in time but is
intergenerational
provides a kind of locus an
inter-subjectivity
that's not hegel's term but it's a good
phenomenological term for the worshiper
and everybody else connected with the
worship to
be
in communion with the god he says in the
cult the two sides have become one
and in the outcome
of the religion of art this unity
in its consummation
we saw this term just earlier
consummation
fulfillment coming to its highest point
right has even gone right over at the
same time
we have now we have something else to
the extreme
of the self
here we should pause for a moment is the
subject
is the substance the same thing as the
self are these different aspects of
spirit
where spirit is most primary the
metaphysical basis and substance and
subject and self are just you know
aspects of spirit hey hegel's not
telling us at this point but it's clear
that there is a distinction between
substance and subject and that self is
either the same thing as subject or
is
an intensification of it and this
happens he says in the cult
so he says in spirit
that is completely certain of itself
in the individuality of consciousness
which we saw was an achievement that
took place
at several different points but the
grand culmination of it was at the very
end of this religion of art section in
comedy right
so this this individuality of
consciousness he says all essentiality
is submerged essentiality would be the
substance
and he goes on and he says now here we
have have uh some some important
propositions right and hegel likes to
frame things propositionally you could
go all the way back to the preface to
see him talking about that and you can
think about this as projecting you know
forward into the science of logic where
this is uh treated in a much more
in-depth and abstract way
what is he getting at here well you know
propositions are linguistic they're also
something in thought
and they're ways in which we
make sense out of things we
inquire about them we argue about them
and so what does he have to say
well the proposition that he brings up
here the self is absolute being
now we can we can read in here a
prior proposition that is being replaced
by this
substance is absolute being the spirit
finds out that substance is absolute
being in this case now we have a third
use of the term subject right
substance is the subject
absolute being is the predicate just as
if i were to say
the book is orange or the book is rather
worn out the book is the subject
orange or
is rather worn out is the predicate also
if i deny things if i say the book is
not heavy right it's not heavy to me it
might be heavy to you depending on how
strong you are saying something is not
is also a predicate and the is is a
copula the thing that binds them
together
so in this second proposition which is
the first that hegel gives us the self
is absolute being
self is the subject and it's not only
subject in the sense of agency
it's also subject in the sense of that
which the proposition is about
the predicate is absolute being
is what is being affirmed of the self
so we went from substance to being
absolute self to
the being absolute being rather than to
the self being absolute being and he
says this is a proposition that
expresses
levity right um
and he says the essence the substance
for which the self was only an accident
so the cell the substance what we were
starting with
had selfhood or other cells or whatever
we want to construe the self as in this
sentence of hegel as a mere accident
that's something that's
not really essential to it as something
that's that's extra that might be a
proper accident in aristotelian terms
but
is just an accident something contingent
spirit has recognized that that isn't
the case
the self is
essential
the the essential thing is
the subject or the self and he says that
the essence the substance
has sunk
to the level of a predicate right it is
what's revealed as being
only something said about something else
substantiality is not that important
as we thought it was and then he says
two things that are interesting in this
self-consciousness over against which
there's nothing in the form of essence
spirit
has lost its consciousness what does it
mean to lose your consciousness well you
lose your sight on what it was that you
were paying attention to in the first
place and we do alternate between
consciousness and self-consciousness
don't we so this is a
good starting point and in the next
paragraph we're going to see this uh
expanded a little bit more
this proposition the self is absolute
being belongs quite obviously to the
non-religious actual or secular spirit
and we have to remember which shape of
that spirit it is which expresses it
it will contain the movement and also
the conversion of it which degrades the
self to the level of a predicate and
elevates substance to subject and in
this manner that the converse
proposition does not in itself or for us
make substance into subject or to put
the same thing another way
it does not reinstate substance in such
a manner that spirit's consciousness is
led back to its beginning to natural
religion
on the contrary this conversion is one
that is brought about for and by
self-consciousness itself
since self-consciousness surrenders
itself consciously it is preserved in
its alienation and remains the subject
of substance but since it is likewise
self-alienated it still has the
consciousness of the substance or
since self-consciousness through its
sacrifice brings forth substance as
subject the substance remains
own self
in the first of the two alternative
propositions the substantiality of the
subject merely vanishes and in the
second substance is only a predicate and
both sides are thus present in each with
contrary inequality of value
here however the result achieved is the
union and permeation of the two natures
in which both are with equal value
essential and at the same time only
moments
so that spirit is simultaneously
consciousness of itself as its objective
substance
and simple self-consciousness communing
with itself
paragraph 749 if you don't know hegel
all that well at this point
might seem rather surprising it's the
second paragraph in this new
final section of the religion portion
the revealed religion and we don't find
hegel talking very much about religion
at all here
we would expect something like a
preamble or an introduction to the
notion of revelation and how that's
distinctive from other kinds of religion
instead we get a treatment of subjects
and predicates and the only time that
religion is being really invoked here is
in terms of the non-religious spirit
which we'll come to in just a moment
so
what do we have going on here well hegel
is unpacking some metaphysical and moral
developments that have been brewing for
a while and that are consolidated in
this proposition the proposition the
self is absolute being
and then he tells us
this belongs quite obviously i'm i'm not
sure how it's quite obvious to everybody
else but he says it's quite obvious to
the
non-religious and he uses the word you
know
religiosa there for the non-religious
actual via clique spirit now he doesn't
have
what miller has here in brackets or
secular right but non-religious or
secular okay though those are basically
the same sort of thing
so the spirit of the age that's what
secular would mean
and
this is kind of a an interesting remark
it almost seems like a throwaway
maybe we'll come back to it in a bit so
this proposition belongs to
this and he says we have to remember
which shape of that spirit it is
which expresses it
which
spirit is that well
you know we talked a little bit in the
last paragraph how hegel's remarks about
comedy which is not really about comedy
as a genre but more about a kind of
secular rising
pull the gods down by us sort of
development which risks a kind of
nihilism
which we we didn't explore before
but we're going to come to in just a few
paragraphs where hegel announces god is
dead right
uh long before nietzsche brought it up
so
you know
maybe maybe that's what we have to keep
in mind maybe the spirit that we're
talking about here is the one that's
brought us now into a new shape of
religion out of the previous one
and he says that now here's this is
quite important it will contain the
movement and also the conversion of it
so this is something that has been
accomplished already right the movement
the bevel
and the conversion the um
and this is a term
that hegel is going to
use both in a noun and a a sort of
verbal or actually adjectival sense and
um
is to so the cara is to to turn right
and so think of it as like turning and
turning in multiple dimensions at the
same time
conversion
is a decent translation things are being
set into a different
light not a different framework but a
different
form a different
function
so
what happens here he says
it contains
the the shape contains the movement and
also conversion of it which which does
what
which degrades the self
to the level of a predicate and elevates
substance to subject so we get the
starting point that we've talked about
before and we've seen many times where
really you know consciousness and
self-consciousness is what is driving
this entire process this is a human
process for human beings the development
of human consciousness but we human
beings have a tendency to try to look
for the substance the thing that is most
essential the thing that is more
important than us the perceiver and part
of the hegelian process is to say
whoa buddy
actually you're the one who's
constituting this it's not you know
totally radically constituting you and
everything else
there's there's a humanization of
substance that takes place now
substance becomes the subject the
subject is the thing that is the most
important it is what is being talked
about
substance as we've seen lacks agency
typically in hegel although if it's
brought together in the right way with
the subject
maybe not
so substance and then we have the self
as a mere predicate and we could think
about this
hegel doesn't go into any detail here
but what is the self as predicate
we can think of other
terms that come out of you know
aristotelian logic something that is
accidental he invoked that just in the
in the previous paragraph accidental
means that it's something that the
subject could either have or not have
and still remain the same subject some
accidents as aristotle and you know
later scholastic spelled out are proper
accidents but they are still not the
essence of the thing
so
what we've got here is an initial way of
looking at things how is this reflected
in
what we've transversed in the religion
section and what we're going to be
seeing
going back to the unhappy consciousness
which will get invoked in the next
paragraphs
well
god has been the substance or the gods
or the divine or the divine law or
whatever it is that we are making the
most important and sometimes this can
leave the gods behind and become just
fate shikhsal or necessity note
vendikait right the greek anke
so all of that is on this side and then
the
self is the self of the worshipper the
self of the producer of statues the self
of the
heroes who are acting within the drama
and the actors uh depicting them right
and the self is less important the self
conforms itself to the substance and in
doing so explores the substance
and this readies us for the um
the
conversion so he says that
in this manner
the
converse proposition
does not
in itself or for us make substance into
subject
or to put the same thing another way
it does not reinstate substance in such
a way that spirit's consciousness is led
back to its beginning to natural
religion so this is quite interesting
let's put aside the moment that not for
us not in itself bit right
and think about what's being said here
we don't have just a going round to the
same point and a new thing being
assertive oh we finally found the real
substance
no there's there's an important
transformation that's taking place this
is not substance 2.0 or substance 3.0 or
anything
like that something new has happened and
that's why we don't go all the way back
to
natural religion and we could go back to
natural religion because natural
religion was the first
of three
developments the third of which we are
now at the beginning of instead of
having like first development
a lot of cool stuff happening here
second development more you know
progress being made more
self-consciousness and complex ways
now we're not going back to this we're
going ahead
to the third section
that we're now exploring the third kind
of religion revealed religion
so if we went back to the old one then
we would be
you know once again
making substance into subject or
reinstating substance we're not going to
do that
on the contrary says this conversion
is one that is brought about for and by
self-consciousness itself
we'll come back to that in a moment as
well because that's important too since
self-consciousness surrenders itself
consciously
it is preserved in its alienation
and remains the subject
of substance
but since it is likewise self-alienated
it still has the consciousness of the
substance
or since self-consciousness through its
sacrifice brings forth substance as
subject the substance remains
self-consciousness's own self a lot
going on there let's unpack it
so
instead of substance being the subject
we now have the self as the subject and
it's the self
as self consciousness
and then we have the substance as the
predicate so we have an um we have a
conversion
you could say reversal if you like
but it's not really just a reversal
there has been some progress
made in this
because you know the substance can't
actually know
its relation to
the self or self-consciousness is
subject to predicate but over here we
have a
self-consciousness who not only is the
subject
but is the subject in another way they
know themselves to be the subject they
know that substance is in relation to
them
it is and it is not this is to signify
there is alienation and feimdong going
on becoming other becoming
hostile alien different however you want
to
translate it alienation is going to be
an important term
throughout this
this section right
so
it's preserved in its alienation
why because self-consciousness
surrenders itself consciously
in the way that it understands its
relation to
substance
this is a transformation of
religion it's also a transformation
that's taking place
as hegel noted for the non-religious
actual spirit
religion and non-religion
exist interfused within a world
this is a little bit of a rant
anybody
who is stupid enough to buy into
facile crap histories about you know the
medieval times being the dark ages or
the age of faith really when you hear
somebody say stuff like that you ought
to just dismiss them because they don't
know what they're talking about and they
got their information from other people
who either don't know what they're
talking about or deliberately obscured
things because they're ideologues and
needed to you know feel superior to the
medievals
if you actually spend much time in
medieval literature you will see the
interfusing of faith perspectives with
incredible secularity
and you know on and on and on and you
will see development taking place
right hegel is not worried about that
hegel actually does buy into some of
that himself
for him you know protestantism and
specifically lutheran protestantism is
going to be the going way but that's
that's a little bit of a side thing here
so uh back to this
this conversion um
self-consciousness surrenders itself
consciously preserves
itself in its alienation and remains the
subject but it is likewise
self-alienated it still has
consciousness of the substance it
doesn't think that itself is the be-all
and end-all
why because it is
self-alienated
and this is kind of good for it this is
you know keeps it from being too
prideful right but it is also something
that's going to be overcome later on
a little bit later
sends self-consciousness through its
sacrifice brings forth
substance as subject
self-consciousness realizes that the
reason why substance has been able to be
subject is because of self-consciousness
and so this substance remains
self-consciousness's own self
now
before going on there's one more thing
we need to attend to these distinctions
right you said the converse proposition
does not in itself or for us make
substance into subject right
not for us
so
there's it's not being
done in such a way that we're just
witnessing it
not in itself not being driven by its
own
factors but rather
for
and
by
self-consciousness itself through
self-consciousness itself right
self-consciousness is doing this
through and to itself
self-consciousness is the one that can
actually realize subjects have
predicates or think about any of this
sort of thing
at all
so coming back to the the end part
he talks about two alternative
propositions in the first the
substantiality of the subject merely
vanishes in the second substance is only
a predicate both sides are thus present
in each with contrary inequality of
value that sounds like an impasse
but
he says here however
the result achieved is the union
right and permeation
word that also has this
in it right
through each other
of the two natures in which both are
with equal value so there isn't an
inequality of value essential and at the
same time only moments this leads us to
a realization that spirit
is once again two things and and this
goes back to the very beginning of the
religion section consciousness
self-consciousness
religion is bringing them together those
are both important aspects of spirit
consciousness here is not consciousness
of the world or consciousness of the
gods or consciousness of the other but
consciousness of itself
as its objective substance
gigenstendlika right something that can
be projected for itself we might think
of this as again you know something in
terms of foreshadowing or imagination or
representation and then we have simple
self-consciousness communing
with itself both of these are
aspects both of these are how spirit is
working at this point in time they are
distinct from each other but they are
not divisible
from each other
and so this is the unpacking of this
this proposition
the self is absolute being
you